last night a low-level former Trump aide
was all over the network's
acting erratic angry armed with little
real information still the media ate it
up some cooperate what do I have to
spend maybe hours going over my emails I
think it would be funny if they arrested
me by the way I think my lawyers gonna
dump me what do you think Muller is
gonna do to me
you know I'm not a lawyer I don't know
Trump may have very well done something
during the election with the Russians
and if we clean it out if he did that I
don't know talking to you yeah I have
smelled alcohol on your breath
well I have not had a drink you have
another drink so that's not know
anything else no no no besides my meds
okay antidepressants is that okay that's
not good
MSNBC called this whole thing historic
but for everyone else it felt kind of
sad and odd it reminds me of the footage
we run when someone freaks out on an
airplane flight we air it because it's
so much fun to watch or when someone
loses their temper and his store and
shouting at a clerk we air that tape
because it's so much fun to watch just
like high school
when a fight breaks out we'd all crowd
around to watch because it's so much fun
thanks to the plethora of cameras a
person among 300 million having a really
bad day becomes a delightful segment and
it's obvious here when it comes to news
we've lost perspective in overdrive to
fill the daily recommended allowance of
anti-trump ism everything becomes a
banner headline including some poor guy
acting manic on-air either caused by
drug side effects booze or Roger stones
advice hard to tell the difference at
times one newscaster accused nunberg of
drinking just there well if you smelled
the booze on time why'd you have them on
we're the optics just too good or was it
because you knew the guy was gonna dump
all over Trump the bottom line we all
love a good meltdown real or contrived
until it's us doing the melting down
then we hope to god there isn't a camera
nearby because if there is all
compassion goes out the window